Bonsoir.
Salut.
Il y a eu un drame à la boxe
mais je vais quand même
emprunter une expression : il
n'y a pas eu de K.O hier. Il n'y
a pas eu un grand gagnant.
- Je vous dirai que ce débat
arrivé le jour même où on avait
un sondage de près de 3000
québécois québécois est
important pour avoir fait 17
débats des chefs je peux vous
dire que vous en tenez compte de
ce sondage de cette importance
le bloc était de 34 % chez les
francophones les libéraux 29 et
les conservateurs travails.
Yves-François Blanchet a eu le
meilleur débat. Permettant peut-
être de progresser tout au moins
de maintenir le corps actuel.
Justin Trudeau a eu un bon
débat. Mais il n'a toujours pas
répondu à la question s'il avait
été majoritaire aurait-il
déclenché une élection? Je me
souviens que lors du
déclenchement de l'élection sur
les ondes ici et dans d'autres
médias que ces questions va
durer. Les gens m'ont dit que
cette question va disparaître 48
heures. Ça fait trois semaines
la question toujoursla. Les
Canadiens sont fragiles ça. 56 %
ont une opinion favorable Justin
Trudeau. Monsieur Singh n'a pas
pu s'imposer. Ce n'est pas grave
pour le Québec. Monsieur O'Toole
était neutre. Il n'a pas reculé
il n'a pas avancé mais c'est
acheté des problèmes. Les armes
à feu et les discours....
sur les transparences en fait il
n'a pas voulu répondre. Quand il
dit qu'il y a un contrat c'est
un contrat pas signé. Justement
il y a un contrat signé entre le
fédéral et les provinces sur les
garderies puis il refuse de dire
il va la respecter alors comment
avoir confiance en quelqu'un qui
veut signer un contrat mais je
ne suis pas capable de respecter
un contrat signé?
- Votre résumé de la soirée.
- Mon résumé n'est pas tout à
fait identique à celui de
Gilles.
On a eu un départ à la hauteur
de la course c'est-à-dire qu'on
a une course serrée.
Oui, rapidement pour les chefs
je pense que Trudeau était
bagarreur. J'ai trouvé que ces
deux pieds en avant pas du tout
sur la défensive sauf sur la
question du déclenchement des
élections. On pourra y revenir.
Monsieur O'Toole, Gilles a
raison. Il voulait traverser
l'épreuve sans perdre de plume.
Et moi je pense qu'au final, il
n'y a peut-être réussi. Monsieur
Blanchet, je ne suis pas
d'accord avec Gilles je pense
pas qu'il a gagné. Je ne pense
pas qu'il a perdu. Son style, on
n'y reviendra. Il y a le fond et
la forme. Sur la forme il y a eu
plusieurs impairs.
On évite pas et qu'on se
arrivé avec lui.
Singh est un touriste à ce
débat.
- Je suis presque d'accord avec
Michael.
La chose qui est bonne pour
monsieur O'Toole c'est qu'on se
retrouve pas aujourd'hui Patrice
et c'est-à-dire : sa course
électorale et les manquer. Il ne
pourra pas s'en remettre, tout
le monde des lampions pour le
débat en anglais. En espérant
que... on ne répète pas
l'histoire. Je ne pense pas qui
va passer dans les annales.
J'ai trouvé... la soirée
dimanche passée beaucoup plus
intéressante d'avoir chacun des
chefs un à avec vous trois pour
pouvoir observer comment il
répondait aux questions parce
que de toute façon ils ont pas
mal dit dimanche les mêmes
choses. On entendit ça toute la
soirée presque en boucle. Des
fois j'avais l'impression que je
pouvais me lever et revenir.
Ce sont deux formules
complémentaires.
J'ai un débat la semaine
prochaine.
- Ce que je veux dire par
compte, ils n'y a pas grand-
chose qui vont rester de ce
débat. Gilles a raison sur la
question des armes à feu.
- On a besoin de précisions.
- Ils ont tous bien performer.
Ce n'est pas toujours le cas
qu'on a quatre chefs qui peuvent
s'exprimer aussi bien en
français alors je pense que
c'était formidable. Précisons
toujours bien performer pour moi
la question : qui a fait ce
qu'il devait faire?
Et selon moi, c'est probablement
plus Trudeau. Et je vais
m'expliquer. Le débat hier soir
à contenu des performances des
deux qui sont de la vente dans
les sondages Québec pour moi,
j'analyserai que ça veut dire
qu'il y a des voies qui vont
bouger.
C'est une bonne nouvelle pour
Trudeau et Blanchet.
Avec les risqués avec la façon
de la campagne qui allait
jusqu'à ce moment-là je pense
que Trudeau est sorti gagnant.
Je suis d'accord que Singh
n'était pas aussi agressif que
les autres malgré que les autres
étaient agressés également même
temps. Je vais juste ajouter une
chose. La performance hier soir
était bonne.
C'était une semaine enco